léonard as tu vu ma raquette de tennis
je ne comprends pas je l'avais laissé
sur la table hier elle devrait être là
haut c'est urgent je dois aller ferrat
un tournoi avec mes amis les lapins
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe dans
cette maison mais c'est chaque fois que
j'ai besoin de quelque chose de précis
je ne le trouve pas
pendant rien ici léonard est ce que tu
aurais vu ma raquette de tennis s'il te
plaît
pardon hein tu me parles bien sûr
hâtives ou tu que je parle à ses parents
à toi à moi a bien sûr mais c'est
complètement stupide il pas du tout
qu'ils croient thekil par les
francs-maçons crusoé paris - robinson
crusoé regarde c'est ce que j'entends
dire la
robinson crusoé
réclusion passionnante avons maintenant
laissez moi finir mon livre ah non non
non il en est pas question 1
pendant deux mois et pourquoi un si
c'est un promoteur à kate hanni la
dernière
bonjour mon sens c'est un peu ma
raquette
et que voudrait que le livre que tu es
en train de lire à quoi tu voudrais lire
le livre mon livre ce même livre que je
lis quoi non mais alors mais c'est moi
qui ai commencé ce livre le premier et
c'est moi qu'ils finiraient le premier
c'est un point c'est tout alors
je ne vois qu'une solution et je peux
savoir laquelle peut-être non monsieur
françois j'ai besoin de toi as-tu avec
les enfants c'est très bien vous allez
pouvoir m'aider
mais que tarif qui leur proto souffler
explique-nous ce qui se passe voilà je
voudrais que vous me racontiez
l'histoire de robinson crusoé
oui un petit peu alors allez-y je vous
écoute qui était robinson crusoé
oui
oui c'est le héros d'un livre qui a créé
un romancier anglais qui s'appelle
daniel de flou et alors que lui est il
arrivé à ce robinson poserait
vivre et il me restait pendant vaincu
les gi
il a organisé sa vie oui c'était une île
déserte c'était une île déserte donc
robinson crusoé était tout seul parc est
il arrivé
il y avait
du talent et des lives les déçus de leur
prison mobile appelée ventre et pourquoi
l'at il
exactement
exactement et comment l'histoire il lui
est arrivé évidemment énormément
d'avancé c'est un très très beau livre
on y croit beaucoup car il ya énormément
de détails c'est fait c'est formidable
et comment l'histoire s'est elle
terminée l'histoire d'un
jour qui manie
la langue
exactement
voilà qu'ils ont écouté mes amis
vraiment je vous remercie encore une
forme arrêté très utile à résulte il
sur une île à mai mais nous aussi nous
vivons sur une île à eau mais ça me
donne une idée
un facteur
savez du courrier pour moi et non
mademoiselle julie je regrette je n'ai
rien pour vous je suis désolé mais moi
factor vous avez reçu l'accolade et ont
franchement je n'ai pas courrier je n'ai
pas de courrier du tout aujourd'hui je
fais ma tournée par habitude pour pas
m'ennuyer au bureau de poste c'est vrai
mais regardez troisième salle être là
y'a rien du tout ou rien du tout
étrange non mais
ya pas eu de bateaux pas du tout pas de
bateau non plus mais non mais non ne
nous expliquer nos facteurs écoutez
c'est très simple j'ai attendu sur le
quai pendant deux heures ils rien pas la
moindre fumée à l'horizon ça c'est
incroyable
pour sûr il suffisait d'envoyer un appel
radio
nous avons essayé françois impossible
mais pourquoi que s'est il passé
la radio qui nous relie à la côte la
radio de monsieur motion dalle est en
panne et là est alors bien la radio nous
sommes complètement coupé du reste du
monde voilà
mes mais c'est pas possible
mais c'est une catastrophe si la pile en
vérité ça nous sommes complètement
isolée plus grave c'est qu'on attendait
aujourd'hui les provisions pour tout le
mois c'est vrai mais il faut on ne peut
pas rester comme ça au côté moi mais bon
ami momo moi cette histoire
en coupe les jambes
écoutez il faut absolument réunir tous
les habitants de l'île aux enfants et
prendre une décision c'est ça françois
raison pas d'affolement mais non sa
folle on passe surtout exactement une
décision ont visionné bien moi je vais
téléphoner à leonard casimir monsieur
tout le monde à tout le monte vous
facture pendant ce temps là vous courez
chez monsieur vos chaînes et voulait
demander de réparer le plus vite
possible la radio à l'erreur chez les
courges
aller où aller ou leonard françois
repoussoir j'ai pu joindre tout le monde
sur casimir léonard m'a dit qu'elle
n'avait pas vue de la journée c'est
ennuyeux remarque il a dû certainement
apprendre la nouvelle
notre île n'est pas très grande et ce
genre de nouvelles en a rapidement fait
le tour tu vois quelque chose là sinon
je lis je ne vois que la mer à perte de
vue
avant des amis
pour sûr c'est encore plus
catastrophique
que se passe t-il fait des robes à la
radio de monsieur beauchesne et
irréparable une vis tient du se dévisser
tout a dû tomber un mais il faut prendre
le bateau pour aller en chercher le
monde une vis qui a disparu dites vous
salut tout le monde
sait que cette tenue
tu connais la nouvelle caisse évidemment
nous allons vivre tous ensemble la
merveilleuse aventures de robinson
rejouer
merveilleuses aventures de robinson
et moi kazim et
casimir ne serait ce pas toi par hasard
qu'ils auraient dévissé une vis dans la
radio de monsieur beauchamp ouais et
alors comment nous sommes coupés du
monde et toi tu dis oui et alors je
comprends pas je vous donne une occasion
exceptionnelle de vivre une aventure
merveilleuse et vous épauleront il ya
des moments où la réplique tu me manques
pour te répondre kazim kazim le dr
pourquoi n'y at il jamais arrivé là
alors là là c'est le plus drôle avant de
dévisser la petite vie ça j'ai appelé le
commandant du bateau et je lui ai dit
qu'il y avait une épidémie de coqueluche
du religieux et qu'il ne nous rappelle
pas donc on va l'appeler aurions pas
nous mêmes par radio
excusez-moi facteurs mais moi je ne
trouve pas ça drôle du tout vraiment
casimir tu va rendre immédiatement cette
vie ça monsieur beauchesne a mais c'est
totalement impossible
je les perds but dans le petit bois vous
ne semblez pas un roman mais nous allons
vivre une aventure exceptionnelle
je n'en suis pas tellement sûr
pas loin non ce sera très drôle
d'ailleurs cette histoire m'a déjà donné
fin quand est ce qu'on a pour source
c'est ça le problème comment quel
problème est bien le casimir us premier
devait nous apporter les provisions pour
le mois vous voulez dire qu'il n'y a
plus rien à manger sur cette île rien du
tout mais c'était pour voir tableau mais
que faites vous la rendez vous que vous
vous devriez déjà être en train de
chercher en train de chercher courmelles
la vie de la petite ville de la radio de
monsieur beauchamp j'ai perdu dans le
petit bois invite n'est pas tendre okada
6 me
[Musique]